señora Guzmán en primer lugar como
Ciudadana de Cúcuta ciudad fronteriza
con Venezuela Cómo vive esta apertura Y
cómo le ha afectado el cierre durante
estos años
Bueno muy buenas noches a todos
el cierre fronterizo desde el año 2015 Y
acentuado a partir del 2019 para el
sector logístico que sirve sobre la
frontera de Colombia con Venezuela en el
departamento del norte de Santander fue
nefasto ya que se perdieron
casi 1.200 empleos de los cuales
veníamos funcionando de años atrás
esto el día de hoy un día histórico
donde pudimos alcanzar la alegría de
volver a tener nuestra frontera activa
con el paso no simbólico sino real de
estos vehículos Ya que fueron ocho
vehículos que pasaron de Cúcuta para San
Antonio y el de Venezuela hacia Colombia
pasaron seis vehículos por los dos
puentes Entonces estamos muy muy
contentos muy emocionados estamos dentro
de una Euforia que estamos queremos de
que no sea
temporal sino sea para siempre esta
reactivación económica no debió haberse
cerrado nunca
para que nos nos perjudicó enormemente a
nosotros los usuarios en esta frontera
esperan que la reapertura traiga
beneficios económicos rápidos o puede
ser todavía un proceso lento
debemos de empezar a crear confianza si
no creamos confianza los importadores y
los exportadores no van a querer volver
a trabajar por esta frontera debido a la
inseguridad en cuanto a que hoy cerramos
la frontera mañana la abrimos hoy
permitimos mañana no permitimos entonces
este tipo de inseguridades no se pueden
dar porque no creamos confianza y si no
creamos confianza no tenemos operaciones
Sí y por tanto a quienes dudan de que se
deba retomar relaciones con el país
vecino usted que les diría como vecina
de Cúcuta
Mira es que es que yo todavía no he
podido entender el porqué del cese de
operaciones nuestro si bien es cierto
Colombia tiene tres fronteras terrestres
importantes que son
por la guajira en el norte que colinda
por
el primer el primer paso fronterizo en
Venezuela es guarero
y nosotros el primer el último paso para
poder entrar a Venezuela se llama poder
paraguachón
por allí nunca tenemos tres tres tres
fronteras tenemos la de la guajira
tenemos la del norte de Santander Y
tenemos la de arauca nosotros por la
guajira nunca Se cerraron las
operaciones por norte de Santander Se
cerraron las operaciones
no entendimos Por qué nos castigaron de
esa manera si es la misma frontera es el
mismo país y es el mismo Venezuela el
que está recibiendo nuestras nuestras
importaciones y exportaciones pendulares
que hacemos y las negociaciones de
comercio